i'm here to talk about perspective
and i've i've seen today's talk and
i kind of feel like mine is a little bit
silly but
hopefully you'll find it interesting so
i'm going to introduce myself and a
really good
drawing drawer i try very good
so a web designer like most people here
and i teach web design and in university
i'm also a community manager at that
part of university
that's really fun and well i have
this aca visual communication with adobe
photoshop
this exam and then when i go
google adwords certified and
crazy thing about me i'm a coffee addict
i drink a lot of coffee
i'm one of those harry potter crazy fans
that
dress like harry potter from time to
time so
um now let's go with perspective
so what we must wonder is what is
perspective
we're going to look into the dictionary
this we find this
the perspective comes from latin
perspective
it means to see through and it's an
approximate representation
on a flat surface such as paper or our
computer
of an image that is seen by the eye i
don't know if
any of you have studied um
television or something like that and
there's always like
white balance a lot of things
because everything we see on tv or we
seen on the
screen it's never like the icy seats
the ice is with depth in the screen
there's no left
so now we can create it with css
so basically perspective have three
elements
those are point of sight horizontal line
and vanishing point those are things of
graphics you know really css
so the point of sight is something like
this is
the point to which and the eye of the
observer
is supposed to be directed when he looks
so if we are
sitting down we have a different point
of sight and if we are standing we have
another different
and there's this the horizontal line
and which is also known as the horizon
which resembles that
horizon or boundary that line
that seems to part the ocean or ground
from the sky forming the shondin line
so this could be this as well
and it's determinate but the point of
sight which is determined by the real
or supposed vision of the viewer so if
we are sitting down or we are standing
it will change
and the vanishing point is not this
movie
but it's something different and
is the point on the horizon at which
receiving lines of the perspective
converge
it could be one or more than one in this
example there are two
but in this one for example there's only
one and it's always
on the horizontal line so it could be
used in photography as well we have
the vanishing point in the middle and we
see that
every line goes to that point um
there's kind of a golden rule we must
listen to that says that objects are
drawn as smaller as a distance from the
observing increases
that means that we can make funny
photographs such as this one
or even funnier this one so
you can go and try this outside and
well what is prospecting what design
what
why am i talking about point of view and
all that
well perspective and means that we are
going to play with
the axis of things z axis y-axis and
the citation so we are moving the
elements through those
those places so it's and we're going to
use the transform property
which we know because it's the scales
things skew
rotate translate
and we can make salad out of it as well
mixing all of them and what we must
remind is that the original space
of the element is still occupied even
though we do this
so we have something called transform
origin which
has been mentioned today already um
it's really easy we have here and both
elements
with the same transform which is rotate
40 degrees
and scale 0 and 0.6
both exactly the same but if we add to
this one a transform origin
we see that what's known as the anchor
point or
the pi volt changes so transform
origin
we could put and top right
and now when we hover over it it goes to
the top right
so we change that point which could be
also our vanishing point um besides
putting the things we can also put
percentages but we know we heard today
that there are
a few batch back backs with it and but
we can put
numbers such as um 200
and 0 which is exactly the same
or we can put as well numbers that are
outside the element
this element is 200 pixels wide
and 200 bit says height so we can put
400 even though it's outside the element
and we get this
so what we find here is a little problem
because when the element moves we lose
focus of
it and it goes really crazy like this
so we must fix this and it's really easy
to fix
and there must be very ways the one that
i found was
using a father such as darth vader
over here so here you are uh
when we hover over the father we
activate
the the transform so thank you
and i was going to put the board that he
has no children so
so this is our html we have daddy over
here
we have the div that we want to
transform
so when we apply our css
we ask and darth
that means the father and when we hover
over it
we activate div that means this red one
over here and we change it so we can
now put whatever we want in transform
origin
modify this and it goes crazy but we
don't lose focus
because we are covering further or darth
vader
so that's one good solution for for that
well how do we use perspective with this
is it could be simplified in three
steps first we create that parent
element
then we apply transform style pressure
3d
and then we apply a transfer perspective
with a value
so here is a daddy which is
red we can see it if we
do this it's right and we have the sun
which is this
green one and we are going to work with
a zone
once it is applied transformers time for
the 3d
perspective 600 and so we can
transform for example rotate
the x and axis maybe
three degrees and we get this so it's
pretty cool and it's pretty simple and
we can complicate a little more
if we go over 90 the element turns
around
which is really easy and we can also
apply
transform origin over this
and it gets like this so
this is the basis of
perspective but we can complicate it a
little more
because as you see this is not a random
number
and because if we change it we'll see a
difference
if i put a double of it
we can see that the the perspective is
less intense it's more
subtle and it's not put in a smaller
number such as
200 and what happened is really strange
the element first goes behind the the
father
besides the intensity of the first of
the effects is bigger
so what happens over here when we
cross a line is that we are affecting
the
stacking context of it so
perspective affects and the stacking
contents
such as opacity does i don't know if you
heard what opacity causes this problem
as well
so we have these things that present 3d
creates a new stocking context
and so that's opacity and the value of
the perspective determines the intensity
of the 3d effects
that means for example if we are a
little and
looking at the dog we'll see a big
3d but if we are a human being we may
not
see the effects so big and intense
and we can modify the vanishing point or
the anchor
point by using transform origin
so we can do this really useful
stuff such as a wiper this is a car
wiper
it doesn't really look like this but it
is
so yes it's really useful i know
everyone wants to do this
and then we have backface visibility
which has been talked already
which is really really simple so we have
this element
which is exactly the same as before and
we apply
transform
rotate we can rotate y into instead of x
and if we rotate it like 100 degrees
we get to see the other side of the
element
for example we can put
like this so everything is turned around
and if in in one case we don't want to
see that
back part we can just tell it that we
don't want to see the back
of the elements and that could be done
with back face visibility
simply hidden so now we don't see the
back of the element
but it is still there because if we do
this
we see it until we don't see it anymore
so that's basically backfield's
visibility he does
that he hides the back of the element
which
of course was unable to see before this
property
so um a simple thing to do with
perspective which is
really nice if flipping a card what we
are going to flip now is actually
a letter and so this is our html
we have a father and which
holds all the elements and then we have
another table is kind of
hidden that will help us to not to leave
focus
and then we have the front which is an
image at the back
which is another image so
this will be our css this is our
hogwarts letter
we are getting to the school and so
we have transform style preservative
apply and perspective a hundred
so all we need is first of all to show
in these
two parts and we can do this by applying
position absolute
so we join them like this
and now we have this and so what we
should do now
is um applying the
transform and to turn it around so
we will apply it to
that when we hover over it but we we
actually applied to hidden
because we don't want to lose focus so
he then we have a transform
of rotate y because we want to rotate it
one way and of the other of 190 degrees
which should be the middle so we have
this it's not
quite finished and it turns so that's
okay so what now we need um
simply to show the front in the front
and the back in the back
so for that we simply hide and the back
of the element with back face
visibility
and now we will have this
but it's not exactly right because what
we are seeing here
is and the front in the back and windows
the front is back and the back in the
front so we don't want that we don't
want it the other way around
so it's pretty simple to fix it we just
need
to ask back to transform
and rotate y another 180 degrees
in order to get the front into the front
and the back into the back
so now we do have the elements and it's
really pretty and it's our hogwarts
letter
and we are getting there so that's
simply that
um with a little more of animation and
that
we can do this kind of crazy things and
it just turns around and turns around
forever
so that carries another few things
such as another transformations
and animations so these other components
are really simple and
we're gonna see them here this is what
we saw
by now is simply that
hover and thrown so we turn the element
this is what we see
for now but we have been working only
with rotate y
and rotate x
this is what we get but and besides that
we can also mix them
so now we get to rotate both axis
at the same time and we get this
and besides there's something else we
can turn which is
the sita plane so
you can rotate we're gonna
the sita maybe around 300 degrees
so we can see it right
so we can mix all of the axes
mix them all together this is one way of
doing it
but there's actually a shorter one
and that's rotate 3d
which is a little special we can put
something like this
0 1 0 and a degree
like 45 so when we do this what we see
is that we are activating the y axis
so this one over here refers to y
this one refers to x so is if we put one
one then we get
this because we are activating on both
the x axis and the y
axis and the other one the other zero
is only destroying the mental
there you are the other one is the sita
plane
so now we get this uh we're gonna also
make them separated like 120
15 um 10
and we get sort of this boring
thing so before besides rotate 3d
we also get translate
and translate could also be used in x
or in y and and it simply translates
the element if we put a negative value
it will go this way and if we put a
positive value it will go the other way
so it's pretty simple but
we can mix it as well with other axes
so we could put translate
y
and then mix x and y and it moves
a little bit more and besides we could
use
translate zeta
and we could say just 200
pixels because it's better to saturate
when we are trying out the stuff
so we can see that it kind of gets
bigger
so why does it get bigger because
it's getting closer to us that's
really interesting and we can
sit better if we rotate the element
maybe 50 degrees and rotating away
so now we see that so the translate zeta
what it does
is um to move this
part on this axis of the element
and in a way can any closer to us which
is really useful when we do something
like this
we turn the elements around and it gets
closer to us
and further from us in the process so
there it goes
and it gets closer and further
and translates also has the short
version
which is simply translate
3d and we put different values
like 2.5 negatives
that go up and the other one
could be something like this so we have
this thing once we modify all that
we apply animations we can create
something like
that letter over there
so that
is definitely um a little short
and about browser compatibility luckily
is
kind of nice it goes along with
transform
so every browser has a problem with
transfer property we have it with
perspective
and so in webkit blink
we need prefix but this is say the next
version of chrome will not need it so
luckily we will not need it later
and firefox is okay and sadly internet
exploder
doesn't read pressure 3d so
and we can use modernize or another
thing to fix it well
that's basically all
sorry was a little short and so
that's in case everything so thank you